so we are posed with the question all
else equal which of the following would
likely cause aggregate production to go
up pause this video and see which of
these you think would do that all right
now let's work through this together
this first one says more people enter
the labor force while the unemployment
rate stays constant
well labor is an important factor of
production and if more people enter the
labor force and the unemployment rate
stays the same that means that the
absolute number of people who are
working goes up and if everything else
stays constant the level of Technology
the capital the productivity per person
well then you would expect to be able to
produce more so aggregate production
should go up in this scenario so I'll
put a check right over there the second
one velocity of money goes up this one
is tempting because you might associate
a high velocity of money there's a lot
of transactions going on you might
associate that with a very positive
economy but remember we're saying all
else equal there might be a scenario
where people are transacting more
there's more the money is circulating
faster but the total amount of output
hasn't changed at all there's the same
number of people producing the same
amount of goods using the same
technology in the same capital and so
this does not have a direct linkage to
the output going up all else equal so
I'll rule this out inflation goes up
well this again is tempting because many
times when we are producing at a high
rate when the economy is strong that's
associated with higher inflation but
there's many cases in history where you
might even have hyperinflation when the
economy is actually even shrinking and
remember we're saying all else equal so
there's a situation where the price
level and the rate of the price level
going up is going up but we're producing
the same amount of goods and services
and so I will rule this out a new method
of producing more goods with the same
resources is developed we'll just
imagine a very simple scenario if the
whole economy consists of me and I
produce pencils unless that can produce
ten pencils a day but I just have a new
method of producing
pencils a day with the same resources
with just me and the same access to wood
and the same tools well that's going to
dramatically increase my aggregate
production so one way to think about
this this is our level of technology has
gone up with this which is an important
factor of production so I like that one
10 new farms are constructed well if the
farms are constructed and I will assume
that they are used well we're going to
have more output they're gonna grow more
things our level of capital has gone up
once again another important factor of
production so I like that imports go up
well imports are us taking advantage or
using someone else's output it doesn't
say what it's going to do to our output
so I will rule that out and so this is
quite intuitive we've talked about
factors of production like labor and
capital and technology and economists
often tie this together taking these
factors of production and showing how
they lead to our aggregate output by
using something known as the aggregate
production function aggregate aggregate
production function and it's a fancy set
of words and what I'm about to write
seems like fancy math but as we'll
hopefully see it's reasonably intuitive
the aggregate production function is
that our output is equal to a which you
could view as a measure of our
technology it's often known as total
factor productivity another fancy word
times a function of as why it's fancy
it's using the function notation of our
capital and I know capital does not
start with K in the English language but
K for capital and our labor and this is
all very abstract if we wanted to make
it a little bit more tangible especially
cuz we just have function notation in
here we could say something like our
aggregate output our aggregate
production is equal to our total factor
productivity and then I'll make up a
version of this let's say times the
square root of our capital times the
square root of our labor but in general
and as you see in this example you're
going to see aggregate production
functions that looks something like this
the the radicals or the square roots on
capital and labor might be a little bit
different but they tell the same story
that
if you increase your level of Technology
you're going to increase your aggregate
output if you increase your capital
you're going to increase your aggregate
output and if you increase your labor
you're going to increase your aggregate
output the reason why you might see
square roots or fractional exponents on
capital or labor is this idea of
diminishing marginal returns that first
farm might really add a lot to your
output but maybe that millionth farm
might still add to your output but maybe
at a less level at a lower level same
thing that first those first ten people
might add a lot of output to your labor
but after you already have 100 million
people the next ten will still add to
your output but maybe less at least
that's what these mathematical models
are saying so big picture it's pretty
intuitive that if you hold everything
else equal and if you increase the
factors of production well then that
would likely cause your aggregate
production to go up but economists like
to describe things mathematically and
that's what's going on in something like
an aggregate production function now
last but not least a related idea to an
aggregate production function is this
idea of productivity productivity we
already viewed a as total factor
productivity and but it's really a
measure of the technology and economy
typically when people talk just about
regular productivity they're talking
about output per capita output per
person so really what they're doing is
they're taking thinking about aggregate
production so Y and then they're
dividing it by labour so then they would
divide it by labour so this would be
output per person and so you can imagine
if technology improves holding labour
constant well then your output per
person is going to improve if your
capital goes up which would improve your
output holding labour constant then once
again your productivity would improve
per person you're able to produce more
in your economy